from a basketball standpoint if you
start a little william
what are you getting off the bench done
you dunn has to come in you know this is
a guy who plays chris dunn's played 11
minutes in the series he hasn't played
in the series but
he's kind of like bobby porter he could
you say this is your moment
chris you know he hasn't been playing
been the third guard in rotation when he
was in
with the bulls he was you know starting
at times so he's he's been in
in games so we got to see if you can
play i actually i wouldn't do that i
would start
jeff teague because if you start lou
williams
i i don't see yeah jeff teague uh i
would start him he's uh he's not exactly
on the atlanta hawks
wait what's the other guy in the box big
dummy i'm sorry
no no i want to what are you talking
about well you ain't talking about
i forget i'm forgetting somebody my
mistake i can make it listen i can make
a mistake who's good
who's another guard on the hawks uh
kenny smith no
no seriously no they're they're well
we've
run out of remember brandon goodwin is a
guy who filled in well
but he's also he's also hurt i had the
wrong guy but i wouldn't start lou
williams
yeah because well you would start chris
dunn and let him be in his natural role
because
well because i need some scoring off the
bench he wanted a normal role listen
dunn hasn't played uh but 11 minutes so
he's not going to give you anything
coming off the bench lou williams is
comfortable coming up here
yeah but there's but there's no way at
this point that you're going to be able
to swing a trade for jeff tigg
well no no wait for that you got to get
some points off the bench yeah
yeah williams is a guy who's going to
get his points
and they need a guy who's going to get
the ball to mcdonovich and john collins
and capela lou williams is going to
score for lou williams that's why i
would bring lou off the bench personally